can you pull up with what i just sent
you check this out uh peter dr pry i
don't know if you've seen this or not so
these are 11 luxury doomsday bunkers
around the world right i mean this is
pretty weird a little bit flamboyant but
one of them was very interesting keep
going lower
keep going lower these different designs
okay so this one's a little bit too much
fine this one's in europe
fully okay uh
yeah that looks like that one movie with
uh what was that one movie with that one
uh comedian years ago
from encino man what's the guy's name
paulie sure biodome it looks like the
bio don't keep going
survival
keep going watch this one watch this one
here
watch this one here that's insane that's
insane to me it's going down it's not
going up
so depending on 15 floors so the
penthouse there would be the bottom
floor think about that like h negative
15. keep going down keep going down keep
going down trident lake not familiar
with this area but there you go that's
another spot las vegas underground
shelter doomsday bunkers look at this
one they got a pool there they got a
little house keep going down the
aristocrat
they got game rooms keep going lower the
safe house keep going lower keep going
lower keep going lower okay that one
that one apparently goes up so those
those gates come up this almost looks
like from the movie purge by the way or
i am legend or i am legend yes yes
that's right keep going keep going a
little more to see a couple other ideas
okay this is pretty interesting this is
bunk bed so that's like a military model
uh keep going lower keep going lower fix
the point
lower lower lower lower interesting
shelters at the bottom this is in west
virginia
global seat wow that's good
where's that at where's that at
global seat vault to doomsday bunkers
huh that's very interesting go a little
lower in norway that makes sense we got
kai that would he would be prepared for
something like that so dr pry to go back
to
uh uh
somebody's listened to this and you said
three percent okay to be in the top
three percent you have to make
250 a year
200 a year that's what the three percent
makes because one percent's around 450
500
20 in six figures three percent you're
around 250 a year to be able to afford
something like this right
what what are some places
uh i following up with your meeting that
we had i called a few friends
okay who are you know to see what they
would say one of the guys i called on
who i'm gonna have on the podcast if he
feels comfortable about it he'll talk
about it
he said yeah absolutely i got i got to
spot myself and i'm ready for it he says
do you know your favorite podcast you've
done all year you know which one it is
he's asking i said no who is it he says
it's dr peter pry you know how many
people i've shared that with i said i
don't know and by the way this is a guy
that's a very well-known guy the people
know who this guy is
he says that's a podcast everybody
should watch because most people are not
ready for it i said okay now what
to to
you know put it in context he's in his
late 60s early 70s so he's living in a
different phase of his life
but he said he's got a place in south
carolina
what are some of the common places that
you're aware that people are buying
you know
nuclear shelters or you know doomsday
shelters whatever they call them is it
specific or it's general it can be
anywhere i want to push back please on
this idea that the preppers were talking
about that the three percent that we're
talking about are the three percent of
the wealthiest americans that's not true
the three percent who are preppers uh
you know include are probably mostly
people of the middle class and even
lower income
brackets you know that do that i suspect
there are more of them because i think
there's more common sense among the
middle class and working class people
than there is among the millionaires and
the billionaires
you know i actually don't disagree with
you i don't see them being a little more
paranoid than someone who's super
successful common sense and it doesn't
cause well uh also people who live in
rural areas and uh you know there are a
lot of americans who supplement their
income by hunting okay to get protein
because meat is so expensive
these are people who are still from that
they still have those pioneer virtues
okay that we were talking about that
used to be the virtues and the values
that all americans used to have up until
about a generation ago when we started
changing and becoming more trusting of
the government and expecting government
to take care of us there are a lot of
americans you know from working class
and middle class backgrounds that still
have the old-fashioned virtues that they
inherited from their parents generation
as did i you know my father taught us to
hunt and fish he had never heard of emp
you know but he did that because he had
fed his family through the great
depression by hunting woodchucks and
fishing and so that was part of
preparedness it's not just recreation
similarly now anybody
you know
even people on a modest income can do
something to prepare you know stockpile
food stockpiled you know it doesn't cost
a lot of money to stockpile you know
canned
beans are very inexpensive you know
all kinds of foods that are out there
that are very inexpensive the more you
stockpile the better off you are have a
medicine kit and know how to use it
exercise some common sense if you live
in the middle of new york city you know
might you might want to think about
you know uh where are there still places
that have the old 1950s civil defense
signs you know what is the what building
has the deepest basement you know so so
that if i was concerned about a fallout
and i don't want to stress that you know
we're so terrified about radioactive
fallout actually there's probably not
going to be a lot of radioactive fallout
and that's probably not as big a threat
as people are worried about because uh
the cities are probably not going to be
attacked you know the adversary
uh would make a counter force attack
maybe we should be talking a little
about the basics of nuclear strategy to
educate people about what they're going
to uh what they're going to face
uh you know basically
uh
the
worst case
one of the worst case scenarios and one
of the and this is a scenario i think
that is being advocated to putin right
now as well
we didn't really talk about all the
factions that are out there but uh uh
you know another faction are people who
still believe in uh
field martial vladimir sokolovsky's
uh
approach that was written in the 1960s
and that and that any new any war any
big uh you know any
use of nuclear weapons is going to
escalate to an all-out war so you might
as well launch a preemptive first strike
against all your adversaries you know
and take out the nuclear forces of
britain and france and the united states
to win the nuclear war right off the bat
and go big if you're going to go nuclear
you go big you know this is the
sokolovsky theory and uh and i'm sure
there are still people advocating that
that's why they've built up a first
strike capability with their strategic
rocket forces and that's one of the
reasons putin has been talking about the
satan 2 recently which is their new
first strike weapon okay they've still
got the satan 1 which is very effective
you know it could destroy probably well
over 95 percent of our icbm silos but a
russian counterforce attack there are
two kinds of attacks we think of in
nuclear strategy one is a counterforce
attack where you're trying to disarm
your adversary by destroying his nuclear
forces and then there's the counter
value attack where you go after cities
and industrial areas and the population
centers
almost
certainly you know they would uh if they
went big and and the suckalovsky
faction uh wins out
they would be they would they would uh
execute the counter force attack
uh you know they don't want to attack
cities initially in that first wave
because you want to hold the cities
hostage to force your adversary to
surrender
and so what do they need to attack our
are to execute a counter force attack
they can do it with 500 warheads this is
the equivalent of 50 satan ones 50
satan 1 icbms
could deliver 500 highly accurate
nuclear weapons that would destroy
the 440 icbm silos and launch control
facilities the three strategic bomber
bases and the two ballistic missile
submarine bases and that would destroy
almost all of our nuclear weapons except
for
those that are on the ballistic missile
submarines that see
you know on patrol typically we have a
third to a half of the submarines that
see on patrol it's more like a third
these days because the ohio class
submarine is so old
uh you know and that's about
you know
about 400 weapons that we would have out
there at sea you know that we would have
surviving now what are you going to do
with those 400 weapons go attack empty
icbm silos in russia vacant bomber bases
ballistic missile submarines that are no
longer in port on their side
impervious
deep underground shelters
and then you'll have no nuclear weapons
at all left after you've used up those
400
and that will leave our cities open and
exposed to attack and we would have
we would have no recourse but to
surrender or see our population
destroyed
you know the logical thing well the
reason we have the ballistic missile
submarines on patrol is they are a
secure reserve they're not supposed to
be used
except to deter the adversary from
attacking our cities
so that attack you see that base
basically
be able to
to if you pull that off and destroy our
forces
it would leave them free to commit
aggression against our allies and have
their way with the rest of the world
and threaten our adversary cities and
conquer the world that way uh except the
united states would uh you know would be
saving our cities and uh and uh at least
be safe for the time as long as we had
those that handful of submarines on
patrol out there
so that's how the logic how nuclear
force would work and
because they're trying to limit
collateral damage to the civilian
population the survival of our civilian
population is an important strategic
asset to them
they don't want to maximize casualties
they want to limit the casualties their
objectives destroy those icbms and their
silos which are all located in very low
population areas by the way the
ballistic the same thing with the
the air force bases there's only three
of them
and they would do things like
do low altitude bursts when you're using
your nuclear weapon because this is this
maximizes the overpressure the blast
effect which is what destroys an icb
upsilo or destroys a bomber base but
uh and uh the the blast effect there's
it's called an optimum burst height okay
the higher up you go the bigger that and
and more effective that blast wave is
and this happens to be good from in
perspective of limiting collateral
damage to the civilian population
because as long as the fireball doesn't
touch the ground you're not going to get
any or or very little nuclear fallout
radioactivity
so the counter force attack will not
generate a lot of fallout and
radioactivity so people don't have to
have
nuclear bunkers or or even worry about
uh you know going into some deep
basement in new york city if you happen
to live in new york city those would
that is a good thing to do it's a good
thing to scout that out i'm not saying
you shouldn't have nuclear bunkers i
mean that's a if you can afford it
that's great but what i am saying is
that for the average person or even
people that don't have a lot of money
there's a lot of things you can do
little inexpensive things that would
significantly increase such a bible such
as such as storing food you know
putting aside maybe one percent of your
budget
how many
how much canned food can you put away uh
having a water supply having a medicine
kit knowing how to use it
do you have friends who have a place in
the country so that you might be able to
work out a survival plan with them where
you're going to be able to get to them
somehow so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]